Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Bitte schick mir jetzt keine verschlüsselten E-Mails mehr.
Grödig.
Ich habe Angst dass jemand entschlüsseln könnte.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 254 und nach unserem Kurzausflug auf die kleine Bühne in Karlsruhe.
Wird wieder auf der großen.
Silvester in der Höhle des Löwen Metaebene angekommen und machen Startprogramm hier am 15. Mai 2018.
Welches ist das heutige Datum war schön auf der GPM.
Ja auf der GPN war sehr schön das Event kann man echt empfehlen.
Empfehlen du warst ja jetzt wahrscheinlich 10 Jahren schon öfter oder oder.
So oft war ich auch noch nicht auf der GPN aber den letzten Jahren war ich da.
Ich war insgesamt jetzt dreimal da an.
Tab jedesmal eine andere Location mieten will was auch bedeutet dass ich jetzt letzten 10 Jahre so bisschen verschlafen habe und ehrlich gesagt auf mehreren Ebenen extrem angenehm überrascht war.
Was immer das schönste Gefühl ist auf Veranstaltung ansich und speziell weil bei Chaos Events.
Also die was ich finde sie so besonders gut hinkriegen ist irgendwie die.
Also oder was heißt inkl ist ja auch viel schon sehr guter Nährboden da ne aber so dass man da eben,
sehr gemütlich zueinanderpassen das Event hat ne was diesen die ist Emily area die Lounge dieser.
Bereich draußen und das ist alles so natürlich nah beieinander und dann noch in diesem.
Freundliche Vortragssäle.
Genau dann noch diese ZKM Ausstellung die dann da auch noch eben kurz mal sind nervo do re sowieso für diese ganze medial kulturelle Nähe noch mal hast und so das ist einfach sehr sehr.
Natürlich wieder fügt sich auch so eine Bundesanwaltschaft im Hintergrund als ne das ist auch irgendwie das gehört da auch mit dazu.
Ich weiß genau aus der Kinder kompatibel also ich habe das sehr genossen eine total entspannte Atmosphäre bemerkenswert dass das dann auch so gefahren werden kann mit kein Eintritt.
Alles mega selbstorganisiert und muss auch sagen die Karlsruher haben auch schon eine gewisse Professionalität.
Da erlangt das sieht man ganz deutlich und fühlt sich auch wunderbar in den Reigen und allgemeinen Veranstaltungs Kanon des Clubs mit einem.
Und da kann ich dann auch sehr Kirchheim finden Sie vom Chef von der Winter GP entsprechen.
Also was darauf wieder so laut dieses diese kochgeschichten also irgendwie dann deine Gulaschkanone aufzubauen und hier noch eine Pizza und jetzt mal hier wir brauchen.
Und Reis mit Scheiß.
Genau und so dass das funktioniert und das ist ja.
Bezahlbar wird es the spirit also thumbsUp und auch unsere kurzer Auftritt auf der Bühne super gelaufen volles Haus sehr schöne Atmosphäre toller Saal auch.
Na wir haben ja auch mal probiert live Feedback zu machen ich fand das ganz gut funktioniert tatsächlich.
Da hätte noch mehr kommen.
Ja aber das war ja so auch so der kurzfristig von uns vorher noch.
Ist auch gleich so ein bisschen Gemeinde wenn man irgendwie seid vielleicht mehreren Folgen gewöhnt ist bylock wo setze ich mich hin und hör zu und auf einmal sprechen diese Dosen stimmt auch sagen und jetzt was sagst du.
Hör mal die Moment war ja dann auch durchaus Kompetenz im Raum und das merkt man ja auch in Viking auch nicht unbedingt immer alles richtig hin wir sind fehlbar.
Auch wenn wir es ungern zugeben.
Ja Feedback gab es auch in den Kommentaren.
So etwas bei der bei der GPN auch gut gegangen ist für mich das viel größere Risiko das mit dem Auflegen zusammen mit Anne ist auch gut gegangen.
Ach so du hast ja noch Rum getrunken.
Genau Schunkelmusik ist auch ist auch wider Erwarten gut gegangen.
Ich muss leider leider gerade in dem Moment das Event Halbfinal verlassen.
Also dich deswegen kann es aus anderen Gründen.
Mehr als wir in der Vorbereitung saßen come meinte Reinhard dann noch Reinhard remfort hier methodisch inkorrekt Podcast der Kollege meinte dann noch so also hast du schon rickroll drin und dann haben wir natürlich,
das sehr schöne Idee dass wir dann nämlich das Set beendet haben mit einer Elektroversion von.
Never gonna give you up.
Never gonna give you up und das wurde dann auch honoriert.
Hatte hatte sehr viel Spaß gemacht und selbst arte der ja nun wirklich musikalisch offen also der musikalisch unterwegs ist hat jetzt auch gesagt dass er da auch durchaus Spaß hat.
Und sich jetzt nicht von mir zu sehr schlecht gefühlt.
Hat mir aber auch das ein oder andere Mal geholfen 123.
Muss ich ganz einfach den Tag zu viel.
Mama weiß gar nicht was DJs alle Solaris Waffen ja Feedback gab's musst du mal vorlesen weil es ist ja an die.
Matze Matze schrieb Linus Ich wollte mal fragen ob es vielleicht möglich wäre wird ihm das nächste Mal beim Thema brexit ein bisschen ernster wird das Thema nicht sofort durch eine Verspottung der Briten abzubrechen sondern vielleicht dem ein bisschen mehr Raum,
für deine Gedanken zu geben.
Entschuldigung ich bin ganz toll ich hatte immer den Eindruck dass der Tim das Thema brexit eigentlich nicht gerne behandeln möchte und es sollte immer eine ich wollte ihn immer eine einen exit aus dem brexit,
mit einem dummen Spruch meinerseits anbieten.
Ja ich bin ja auch voll selber im brexit Modus aber leider haben die deutschen Behörden mich noch nicht eigentlich dauert.
Ja
Also ist jetzt nicht so dass ich da nicht drüber reden würde wollen würde zumal ich ja auch in der beneidenswerten Situation bin dass ich jetzt persönlich.
Nicht so sehr davon betroffen bin ne also jetzt mal von der potenzialerkennung meines Evo Status absehen aber da habe ich natürlich auch schon.
Meine meine exit brexit strategy quasi schon weil ich ja hier.
Eigentlich keine Probleme haben sollte die deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft anzunehmen was ich ja auch beantragt habe was allerdings bisher noch nicht beschieden wurde.
Also nicht das also nicht dass ihr Leute beim Bäcker demnächst Angst haben müssen das tun illegale.
Das könnte natürlich passieren ne oh Mann ich sehe sie schon zittern.
Ja aber der matze hat ja in seinem Kommentar auch noch angemerkt dass er ja sehr wohl betroffen ist und das ist tatsächlich auch ein eine eine Bevölkerungsgruppe.
Die tatsächlich in den Diskussionen relativ.
Also wie manch andere auch noch die auch noch betroffen sind da die nicht so sehr zu Sprache, führt halt viel über die,
potentiell europäisiert in Britain die es ja auch gibt gesprochen und natürlich dann die ganzen Heißsporn die halt nichts sehnlicher,
Erwin Streben als die Farbe ihres.
Passes geändert zu sehen was offensichtlich die wichtigste Diskussionen im Nassen Kontakt zu sein scheint.
Und Leute die halt EU-Bürger sind und in Großbritannien leben die handelt sich hier richtig die Arschkarte.
Ich kenne schon einige Leute die das Land verlassen haben insbesondere aber nicht limitiert auf den akademischen Bereich.
Aus verschiedenen Gründen einerseits war natürlich absehbar ist dass die Arbeitsbedingungen sich verschlechtern also.
Während ja der brexit an sicher noch aussteht und das sozusagen immer ja noch nicht ganz klar ist was denn nun die Konsequenz daraus sein wird.
Ist es so dass im akademischen Bereich im Forschungsbereich die Gelder quasi sofort nach der Abstimmung weg waren warum war natürlich ein Großteil der Forschung in Europa davon abhängig ist EU Grenze zu bekommen.
Ganzen EU Programme sind für die Forschung einfach extrem wichtig und das ist ja ein größerer länderverbund den nicht nur EU Länder mit einschließen auch noch so starten wie Israel die da als assoziiert gelten und wenn du halt auf europäischer Ebene.
Gelder beantragen für Forschungsprojekte.
Dann bist du gezwungen in weiß es nicht genau ich habe mindestens zwei drei verschiedene Länder Teams aus verschiedenen Ländern aus diesem.
Aus den genannten Ländern also EU plus X dabeizuhaben muss also quasi breit europäisch aufgestellt zu sein.
Und dauert halt nicht lange und die ganzen Briten sind halt aus allen Projekten rausgeflogen weil die natürlich alle so Gott wenn wir jetzt Briten im Team haben dann kriegen wir uns nicht mehr.
Oder wir müssen noch ein viertes Land dazu nehmen damit du damit man 3 erfüllt hat oder würde das nicht gehen.
Es ging nicht nur um die Zahl sonst wurde einfach generell sozusagen Großbritannien war auf einmal die heiße Kartoffel also die,
die britischen Forscherteams haben einfach extreme Probleme überhaupt noch in irgendwelche Anträge mit reinzukommen war natürlich alle Schiss haben dass sie sozusagen gar nicht mehr bekommen weil Britanien einfach Schichtwechsel das mag jetzt im Einzelnen vielleicht auch eine übertriebene Reaktion,
gewesen sein.
Aber sie war so oder so da.
Aber sie war da ja also quasi das die Involviertheit der Europe der der der der britischen Forscher Gemeinschaft in die europäische Forscher Gemeinschaft die war einfach mehr der weniger von heute auf morgen dahin.
Und natürlich auch langfristige Geschichten wie Beschäftigung von EU Führerschein an Universitäten etc da konnte auch niemand richtig dadurch beruhigt werden das,
Dieter Story government gesagt hat sich Haare gleich mir aber alles aus und was da an Forschungsgeldern,
wegfällt das bitte bei mehrere Jahre Deckelfach interessanterweise eine der ersten zu sagen die sie überhaupt machen mussten ins im ganzen Spiel um da überhaupt noch die Deutungshoheit zu haben also.
Paulaner drauf eingehen diese eigentlich nicht haben und ja.
Und dazu kam halt auch einfach noch dass Leute die Kinder in der Schule hatten sie also auch mehr oder weniger von heute auf morgen auf einmal Sicherheit mit entsprechenden ausländerfeindlichen Aktivitäten da konfrontiert sanasa wurden dann auf einmal die Kinder,
VW auf einmal alles ganz schlimm und total ausländerfeindlich,
und haben die sich halt auch gesagt in den Scheiß muss mir nicht geben ich kann dir irgendwie als Forscher überall unterkommen ich muss jetzt hier nicht in Großbritannien sein ich packe ziehkoffer also da kann ich mehrere Stories,
was natürlich noch geblieben viele Wunder ja vielleicht auch schon sehr lang und in der aktuellen ganzen politischen Debatte innerhalb von Großbritannien ist das immer alles noch so dermaßen überhitzt dass niemand alles genau weiß habe ich überhaupt die Möglichkeit.
Britischen Status zu bekommen bei welchen Bedingungen wie erleichtert mir das gemacht und ich kann gut nachvollziehen.
Ausmaße deinem Kommentar sagt dass das große bodenrüben ist im Big Picture wenn man sich jetzt mal anschaut wie der brexit eigentlich derzeit zusteht.
Ist es halt nach wie vor.
Zurück also die ganze Debatte ist mega absurd und ich tendiere auch schon dazu das was damit dem brexit abgeht schlägt einfach unter trumpismus.
Zusammenzufassen.
Weil genau so irrational wie sich diese amerikanische Regierung verhält genauso irrational verhält sich auch die britische Regierung die ja mal eigentlich gedacht hat mit dieser brexit Abstimmung quasi.
Am längeren Hebel zu sein.
Na vor allem auf dem Graben innerhalb der Tories zu kippen also das ganze war ja eigentlich eine Maßnahme um die zwei Lager innerhalb der Tory Partei zu vereinigen die man sagt Merkel Stimme mal alle für Europa alle dafür gut Debatte beendet.
Fertig so na und was dann kam wissen wir ja und seitdem haben natürlich diese beiden Gruppen überhaupt nicht zueinander gefunden und jetzt geht der Riss nicht nur quer durch diese Partei soll natürlich durch das ganze Land und jetzt.
Gut was ist, das lange nacherzählen was alles passiert ist teilweise werde dieses Jahr auch mitbekommen haben die Situation sieht im Prinzip derzeit so aus.
Supertalent hat im Prinzip.
Noch keine einzige ihrer Forderung umgesetzt bekommen alles was bisher auf dem Tisch liegt sind die Position die die EU vorher hatte während der Verhandlung hatte bis heute hochgehalten hat sitzt bemerkenswert wie die EU da auch ihre Linie hält.
Ja sie haben von vornherein einfach 1008 ausgeschlossen und bisher.
Wenn man vielleicht mal die letzte Sendung angesprochene. EU Domains mal raus nimmt ja ist einfach da der Kompromiss ein ich bisher immer gewesen wäre Kompromisse Silber nehmen jetzt die Linie der EU weil Großbritannien hat halt einfach.
Jammert auch nichts daran meine womit wollen die große Drohnen gibt natürlich Probleme aber die Probleme sind im 2 Fall da wo Probleme für,
die EU Auftritts ist Großbritannien meistens immer noch schlechter dran Automobilindustrie liefern Geschichten Airbus die großen Sachen und Forschung wie schon erwähnt.
Das wird auf jeden Fall harten und wenn man ins Detail reinschaut natürlich eine Menge Konsequenzen erst ganze haben und jetzt,
gibt es alles das Absurde ist deswegen sage ich auch trumpismus die Leute trauen sich derzeit immer noch nicht gegen diese.
Schreihälse ordentlich anzugehen und meine klare politische Position zu beziehen das Schlimmste in den ganzen Spiel meiner Meinung nach ist die Labour Party,
die halt irgendwie so naja sowie die Tories wollen was ja nicht aber so richtig nein sagen zu dieser Abstimmung können wir ja jetzt auch nicht weil ist ja irgendwie Volkes Wille,
wo der Kolben ist ja eigentlich ein alter Sozialist und jetzt auch nicht unbedingt so ein so ein so ein Freund der juhu als,
ansich weil er das halt auch so ein bisschen glaube ich unter Kapitalisten Verschwörung abgespeichert hat und deswegen kommen auch nur so komische Lippenbekenntnis aber wovor sie alle,
richtig Schiss haben also es ist typisch mit vorallem ist schlicht das Verlassen des single market nur ohne single market.
Also du bist 75 nur sagen dass dass ich dass ich komme aber wenn sie halt in den Single mag drin sein wollen bzw in dem entsprechenden Zollabkommen na ja.
Dann müssen sie sowieso wieder alle Regeln der EU übernehmen das ist ja das Absurde ja,
immer noch denselben Regularien unterworfen nur mit dem Unterschied dass wir halt,
keine keinerlei Stimmrecht mehr haben und nicht in der Lage sind irgendwie zu gestalten im Prinzip sowie Norwegen bis in Norwegen ist das irgendwie egal die haben ihre Kohle aus Öl und guten Ideen.
Und komme ansonsten mit allem prima klar nur die Briten wollten ja diese unglaubliche Unabhängigkeit weil sie halt von ihrem alten Empire träumen und der Meinung sind sie würden und wie klar kommen und die Welt würde ihn zu Füßen liegen wir sind jetzt halt gerade,
das ist irgendwie so recht nichts wird mit den ganzen neuen Abkommen und noch schlimmer sie haben als vor allem keine klare Linie weil jetzt auch das.
Das Oberhaus the House of Lords hat jetzt auch mal abgestimmt und gesagt so na ja um die Zollunion wollen wir eigentlich schon haben das heißt hebelermeer ist derzeit noch nicht meiner Lage eine Mehrheit innerhalb ihrer eigenen Position zu.
Bekommen um ihre eigentlichen deklarierten Penne durchzubekommen und alle sagen halt naja also Zollunion wäre es dann doch schon mal ne ganz gute Geschichte.
Das ist das was ich unter privileged partnership zusammenfassen lässt.
Oder geht es sogar darüber hinaus.
Gegenüber der EU meinst du jetzt.
Ja das ist das Inhalt irgendwelche password Sie sie in den Raum schmeißen wo sie immer davon träumen sie können jetzt in irgendeiner Form eine Rolle haben wo sie irgendwie die Wurst essen können ja ohne die ganzen.
Bedingung mit Handy Wurst so kommt irgendwie zu beachten und das Kernproblem der Zeit ist ja ein ganz anderes.
Wird Großbritannien Großbritannien wäre wahrscheinlich alles okay aber Land heißt ja nicht Großbritannien Land heißt ja Vereinigtes Königreich.
Von Großbritannien und Nordirland sind kleine Kinder um was über viele Jahrzehnte ja eine Menge Stress hatte und Bürgerkrieg und was nicht alles gibt's halt auch noch so und.
Und die wollen unter keinen Umständen irisch irische Grenze haben die sie aber haben müssten wenn weil das ja dann quasi wieder ein Nicht-EU-Staat an eine Niere statt wäre.
Ja vor allem es gibt da es gibt da ein Abkommen nämlich das Karfreitagsabkommen was die der Friedensvertrag von Nordirland ist der jetzt ja seit einiger Zeit auch relativ gut,
funktioniert und dafür gesorgt hat dass diese ganzen Bürgerkriegs Unruhen contain sind auch die Hamster immer noch nicht alle Liebhaber sie hauen sich zunächst nicht den ganzen Tag den Kopf rein und dann riesen Fortschritte im Prinzip ja auch die EU gebracht hat und da steht halt drin.
Irland und Nordirland müssen auf eine Grippe haben. Und beide Seiten müssen zu denselben wirtschaftlichen Bedingungen agieren wenn jetzt ruf Bethanien Austritt ist das halt nicht mehr der Fall.
So
dann sagen Sie naja aber wir wollen ja auch eine offene Grenze haben da gibt's ja vielleicht und welche technischen Lösungen sind Ronda von irgendwelchen automatisierten Kamerasystem die Leute dann automatisch überprüft werden und so weiter das,
das ist aber alles nur Gerede weil diese technischen Systeme gibt es nicht also es ist gibt keinen konkreten Vorschlag sonst gibt halt nur,
Gerede darüber dass man sowas ja vielleicht mal irgendwie entwickeln könnte das müssen zittern ab nächsten Jahr.
Ende zwanzig nach Ablauf der Übergangsfrist müsste das ja dann alles greifen und denke wir können beide feststellen solche technischen Lösungen werden so ein Problem mit Sicherheit nicht lösen können.
Zumal die EU halt auch sagt so das ist das ist uns auch irgendwie das ist für uns nix denkt euch mal was anderes aus also eigentlich gibt's die ganze Zeit nur Absagen der EU an Großbritannien aber sie diskutieren halt innerhalb des Landes immer noch.
Zwischen den Optionen die beide irgendwie für die Uhr nicht in Frage kommt so was wäre denn jetzt wenn sozusagen.
Dasselbe Rechtssystem gelten würde selbe Wirtschaftssystem würde defacto bedeuten das Nordirland in der EU ist.
Also wie Norwegen quasi alle Regel macht damit hätten sie aber nicht mehr dasselbe Wirtschaftssystem wie Großbritannien und damit wäre die Grenze zwischen Nordirland und Großbritannien oder zwischen Irland und Großbritannien,
was natürlich insbesondere der kleine Koalitionspartner der Tories nämlich diese wahnsinnigen da die,
wie heißt dieses Mal gleich diese Partei also es gibt ja so sagen die Vertreter die alte schimpfen ne die heißt quasi ihre scheint hier sind und dann.
Im die Royalisten und Unionisten.
Die schon immer zu Großbritannien gehalten haben also quasi die die die die Vertreter der alten Konfliktparteien und.
Da die Tor ist ja bei dieser letzten Wahl auf die Theresa May gesetzt hat nicht mehr die Mehrheit hatten waren sie quasi auf diese spitzer Partei angewiesen und die später weiter sagt nein also hier selber Wirtschaftsraum und selber politischer raumfee,
wie Irland dann sind wir ja quasi Irland zugeschlagen worden und das ist ja das was wir noch nie wollten also ist ein unlösbares Problem.
Jeder weiß dass das Problem nicht lösbar ist trotzdem wird in Großbritannien fortlaufen nur hin und her.
Darüber diskutiert dass es ja irgendwie theoretisch alles gehen müsste nur niemand hat irgendwie nen konkreten Vorschlag zu machen die Labour Partei traut sich nicht da einfach mal zu sagen Leute das funktioniert alles nicht lass mal doch lieber nicht bleiben.
Die einzigen die das machen sind diese libery Demokratie aber ja schon immer so eine Randnotiz der britischen Politik waren weil du natürlich ein Mehrheitswahlrecht hast und dann.
Kommst du halt nie nennenswert zum Tragen die waren ja auch vor einigen Jahren mal mit den Torres zusammen der Koalition haben sich vor dem Tor ist halt über bügeln lassen und sind dann halt auch gleich wieder abgewählt worden.
Lass uns das dass es das britische Drama was ich da entfaltet und das geht nirgendwohin also Großbritannien ist mit 250 Stundenkilometer.
Auf dem Weg gegen die Wand zu fahren und zwar so richtig.
Es ist ganz schlimm und es ist furchtbar und jeden Tag den sie weiter verstreichenlassen mit der sinnlosen Debatte macht alles noch viel schlimmer das geht nicht gut aus.
Wie sehen denn wie sehen denn die Option aus das noch mal abzuwenden man hört ja immer mal wieder so dass irgendjemand gesagt hat er viele machen einfach noch mal ein Volksentscheid.
Gibt natürlich da eine bestimmte Teilgruppe der Bevölkerung die das fordert.
Aber wenn halt beide großen Parteien dieser Forderung nicht anhängen ist da relativ wenig zu holen.
Also derzeit sieht es nicht danach aus dass ich das durch ist kann natürlich sein dass wenn jetzt in den nächsten Monaten die ganze Geschichte weiter eskaliert.
Und weitere deadlines komplett gerissen werden ohne dass irgendwelche Pläne da sind und klar ist das jetzt dann halt irgendwann auch bedeutet das und hard brexit mit keiner Nachfolgeregelungen.
Auf einmal in defekt wäre.
Dann denk ich mal wird es die britische Gesellschaft einfach zerreißen weil all diese Probleme die alle so ein bisschen anrollen kommen alle gleichzeitig ohne Vorbereitung stattfinden würden und das kann nur.
Und das Resultat wird das Resultat eines hard brexit wir doch im Zweifelsfall sein dass sie ihren Hass auf die EU einfach nur noch potenzieren.
Ja Klavier in der Schuld also das ist ja eh klar,
also ist ja jetzt alles sehr lustig dass die Briten immer jahrelang die EU als zahnlosen Tiger der sich ja nicht um ihre eigenen Interessen kümmern würden,
sozusagen bezeichnet haben und jetzt muss ich Ruhe halt wieso eine Löwenmutter die Interessen der Mitgliedsländer vertritt und zwar so richtig krass stark ist in das.
Zu stark machen sag doch einfach nur so ja nee das geht so nicht.
Die Uhr hat schon verstanden dass wenn sie jetzt nicht zusammen stehen.
Ja genau dann dann ist es vorbei.
Du musst jetzt eigentlich also das kannst du dir aber auch das hätten sich die Briten noch jetzt nicht die dir da abgestimmt haben aber das hätten sich ja die Spinner die in Richtung brexit gehetzt haben auch vorher denken können das eben.
Also jedes der Feier imprinter sehr schwerer Vergleich aber das war ja.
Im Umgang mit Griechenland und oder Spanien sind das ja ähnliche.
Sachen das eben klar vertreten wird pass auf so und so waren die Regeln wenn wir können davon gar nicht abweichen.
Selbst wenn das unter Umständen das moralisch geboten wäre da wenn wir das einmal tun oder auch hier.
Unabhängigkeit Kataloniens nein zu sagen sie wenn wir das einmal tun dann fällt uns hier das gesamte Ding auseinander weil dann keiner mehr die Verträge die wir hier über.
Viele Traditionen und Kriege irgendwann einmal geschlossen haben noch für bindend hält das heißt jeder der hier irgendwo,
ein of exit macht der muss von uns die volle Breitseite der kalten Schulter kriegen sonst fällt das alles innerhalb von zwei Jahren auseinander und das ist ja also,
damit will ich jetzt nicht.
Irgendwie das Vorgehen in Sachen Katalonien in irgendeiner Form rechtfertigt noch nicht im Umgang mit Griechenland rechtfertigen Umgang mit Spanien oder sonstigen Ländern in dieser Familie rechtfertigen ich will nur sagen es war vorhersehbar.
Wie sieht,
abzusehen gewesen dass die sich so verhalten würde und dass sie aus ihrem eigenen bestehen heraus aus irgendein Interessen heraus sich auch nicht anders verhalten kann weil die Signalwirkung eben fatal wäre.
Das hätte man sich ja bei der brexit Frage eben auch durchaus denken können.
Hätte man ja mal vor nachdenke.
Dass die EU sich nicht besonders kooperativ zeigen wird wenn irgendwie spontan Leute.
Entscheidende fundamentale Verträge spontan mal eben über Jordan werfen das geht eben dann nicht.
Hätte hätte Fahrradkette aber und das ist halt mein Haupt beklagen. Den ich eigentlich habe gegenüber der britischen Gesellschaft die haben sich einfach so mental so sehr.
Schon immer wie eine Insel aufgeführt und auch sozusagen diesen diesen Gedanken durchgezogen dass sie einfach in diesem europäischen Selbstverständnis nie angekommen.
Unterhält sich halt mit denen sie reden halt die ganze Zeit von europe und du merkst einfach da sind wir von Europa reden dann reden wir von uns.
Wendy von europe reden dann reden sie von The qontinent und das ist.
Ja ganz andere Herangehensweise und überhaupt nicht verstanden was.
Ihre Realität was alles der EU entspringt was zu sagen Indira redet ist und jetzt stellen sie halt fest so andere.
Stärkste Wirtschaftskraft ist also der Finanzplatz und der lebt vor allem dadurch dass er in.
Europa ist und deswegen diesen ganzen Finanzmarkt in Europa bedienen kann was jetzt auf einmal weg verhält so ja wir sind mit unseren ganzen Handelswegen,
und mit unseren Zulieferern fest verschmolzen mit,
Deutschland und mit Frankreich und das fällt jetzt irgendwie alles weg weil auf einmal Hölle da sind womit wir einfach überhaupt nicht mehr konkurrenzfähig teilnehmen können,
oh ja wir reisen die ganze Zeit wissen Ärmelkanal wenn wir es nicht selber tun weil warum die Briten sind die die Insel nicht verlassen wollen tun dass unsere Truck den ganzen Tag,
wenn es irgendwie Zollkontrollen in Dover auf einmal aufschlagen dann gibt's in Dover noch nicht mal mehr genug Straßen Platz wo die überhaupt alle stehen können um da irgendwie 10 Stunden zu warten bis immer durchgecheckt.
Dass dass dass das einfach alles Probleme an die dir stoßen die sind so fundamental und so grundlegend und eigentlich auch unlösbar dass man sich einfach immer noch wundern,
wie es eigentlich sein kann dass du da halt immer noch solche Diskussion für aber du hast halt deswegen sage ich auf trumpismus wird immer noch mit Lügen gearbeitet wird immer noch komplett die Realität ausgeblendet,
du hast auch eine extrem aufgeheizte Presselandschaft wo er da die dailymail einfach,
Sachen raus knallt und die ganze Zeit quasi Werbung für Sonne so so ein Hardcore Fahrt in der Politik nach.
Den Leuten wird halt auch auf eine Menge scheiße erzählt aber sie haben irgendwie die Möglichkeit verloren da den scheiße Filter entsprechend einzustellen meine Zimmer in ansetzen bei uns auch.
Bedarf.de TC und halt den USA auch und ich weiß halt einfach nicht mehr wo das enden soll also die Sache ist.
Habe ich und dieser.
Dieses Höhe die blöden Briten und so sag mal sehen wie sie da jetzt rauskommen und ich selber habe ja auch schon so Anwandlung gehabt es mir nur dachte so ja jetzt bitte aber auch mal richtig alles auf die Mütze damit es mal merken weil das ganze ist natürlich auch,
ein wenig aus seiner Verzweiflung heraus dass ich halt weiß das was Großbritannien der Macht schadet uns halt auch wir werden diese aus.
Wirkung spüren jetzt gibt es schon die Haushaltsverhandlungen ist Hitler wird schon mal höflich gestritten darüber wie weniger Geld jetzt sozusagen untergebracht wird weil natürlich durch Großbritannien einer der Haupt.
Thaler der EU wegfällt und das wird Auswirkung haben und natürlich wird es auch auf so,
Unternehmungen viabus die für Europa extrem wichtig sind enorme.
Vorname ich hätte mal sowas wie Airbus wird halt irgend eine Ausnahmegenehmigung bekommen aber es ist halt durchaus vorstellbar dass das alle auch alles aus Großbritannien abzieht das mag,
hier und da gut sein und Frankreich freut sich dass hier viele große Finanzunternehmen demnächst begrüßen dürfen und in Frankfurt natürlich auch also ich glaube der Großteil wird im Wesentlichen nach Paris nach Frankfurt abziehen.
Aber es gibt natürlich auch eine ganze Menge.
Wo das nicht so schön ist ne und deswegen und das ist vor allem halt auch eine menschliche Tragödie alandi die Briten die halt in Europa wurden ist allein in.
Spanien Wunder 1000000 23a auch gar nicht weg haben oder so und und sag mir mal die Briten im.
Optische Festland die haben noch relativ gute Karten aber halt die Europäer in Großbritannien ich schön da.
Hallo das da könnte auch noch ganz schön eklig werden und ich weiß nicht.
Was kann ich noch alles passieren muss bis man hat die Kurve kriegt so aber das scheint diese Gesellschaft die,
bestreiten und demonstrieren nie so richtig gelernt hat ja die keine Revolution hatten irgendwie seit hunderten von Jahren,
wissen nicht wie sie sich gegen eine Regierung wenden sollen die in die falsche Richtung massiert und das haben wir natürlich immer langsamer auf unser netzpolitische ist auch hier auch mal wieder zu öffnen auch in den ganzen.
Überwachungssysteme ca an wie man mit Privatsphäre und wie man halt mit Überwachung umgeht auch gesehen und gab halten nie einen großen bürgerlichen Widerstand und das Recht sich jetzt einfach das Problem,
das sind in der Lage sind einfach mal ordentlich Demo zu machen.
Z.b. geschweige denn einen breiten gesellschaftlichen Konsens voranzutreiben und um immer zusammen Leute macht jetzt mal die Augen auf die Wand kommt einher sie ist nicht schön.
Das gleich mal dazu dass du so meine persönliche Perspektive so richtig zu berichten gibt halt derzeit nix weil es tut sich halt nichts hören einfach weitere deadlines demnächst reißen und.
Ich könnte mir halt vorstellen dass dass es irgendwie schlimm kommt.
Okay schlimm ist es doch gekommen für Pipi und es meinem.
Ich werde jetzt erstmal die die angriffskette erklären die da gestern veröffentlicht wurde.
Deshalb erstmal die Schlagzeilen die gestern so durchs Netz f*****.
Also die Schlagzeilen sind TIFF König der an.
Deinstalliert Pipi und es mal Mund lieferte gleich Anleitungen für alle irgendwie gängigen Systeme,
NDR kündigte auf Twitter an e-mail ist kein sicheres Kommunikationsmedium mehr,
die Tagesschau schickte Push-Nachricht Forscher knacken E-Mail-Verschlüsselung die szt verschlüsselte E-Mails sind nicht sicher.
Sicherheitsforscher haben die Verschlüsselung von Emails geknickt,
geknackt und hatte da noch die zwischen Überschriften slope für Pipi ist überholt also man könnte sagen.
Die ganz ganz große Pauke wurde geschlagen und es war wirklich so.
Stndr für mich.
E-Mail ist kein sicheres Kommunikationsmedium mehr.
Ja das ist so ein bisschen bedauerlich ne also dass ich weiß jetzt nicht ob man ob dieser Titan auch von denen von den.
Journalistinnen und Journalisten formuliert wurde oder ob der eben aus der Social Media Abteilung kommt oder so man hört ja immer wieder von Journalisten oder dass sie.
Jetzt nicht unbedingt den Einfluss darauf haben unter welchem Titel.
Ihr Artikel da entsteht veröffentlicht wird also wir nennen mich jetzt keine Namen aber ich denke wenn man sich jetzt mal diese Sache im Detail zu Gemüte führt,
ist schon relativ klar dass es hier einer relativ großen Pauke getrommelt wurden.
Und ich will nachher mal.
Beurteilen ob das denn so notwendig ist also kommen E-Mail war auf jeden Fall noch nie in kommen ein sicheres Kommunikationsmedium und insofern ist bald an dem.
Lied von NDR Info auf jeden Fall zu bemängeln dass da ein Meer anstatt aber schauen wir uns mal den Angriff an es geht um.
Gigi P&S mein beide sind Standard sie genutzt werden um.
E-mails ende-zu-ende zu verschlüsseln einfach gesagt ist das so.
Wenn ihr nicht wisst dass ihr Pipi oder erstmal nutzt dann nutzt die es auch nicht.
Bin quasi Standard die oben drauf auf E-Mail irgendwann einmal die in E-Mail irgendwann einmal mit dran geknotet wurden und die Verschlüsselungsmethoden darstellen die prinzipiell auch ohne E-Mail funktionieren können.
Und.
Die sich dadurch auszeichnen dass quasi eine E-Mail vor dem Versand auf dem Rechner des absenden.
Der absenden Personen verschlüsselt werden dann wird ein verschlüsselter Inhalt durch diesen ganzen E-Mail weggeschickt ne vom Ei bei meinem Provider abgegeben kommt beim anderen an und dann wird die findet die Entschlüsselung erst wieder statt.
Auf dem auf dem Rechner der Empfängerin und dort.
Combikorn eben.
Public Private Key Paare zum Einsatz um das zu realisieren JP hat das mit einer mit klassischen,
Public Private Key Slime nutzt dafür Zertifikate in der Anwendung ist der Unterschied eben dass man bei PPP die Verifikation,
das Kies an den Mann sendet mehr oder weniger.
Irgendwie selber machen muss und bei esmeyer anhand der Verwendung von Zertifikaten eine dritte Instanz dafür bürgt sodass ist der Unterschied in der Anwendung.
Okay insgesamt kann man glaube ich sagen dass vom gesamt e-mail aufkommen wirklich eine massiv,
Unterzahl versendet wird unter der Anwendung von ptp31 mein Wasser durchaus auch ein.
Ein größeres Problem darstellt.
Okay soviel zum Problemfeld das heißt also für die meisten unter euch heißt es ihr seid sowieso nicht betroffen.
So jetzt baue ich den Angriff den erkläre ich jetzt von hinten also,
Kaze ich fange damit mit dem letzten Teil des Angriffs an und arbeite mich zum ersten Teil des Angriffs hervor weil ich glaube dass das eine eine dass man es so einfacher versteht.
Es gibt in Emails seit einiger Zeit ich weiß noch nicht mehr genau seit wann habe ich glaube schon seit den 90er Jahren die Unsitte.
Ja dass man diese E-Mail in HTML formuliert und formatiert,
HTML also das war es worin eigentlich Webseiten geschrieben werden man kann also nutzt einfach die gleichen Formatierung Text aus HTML um in einer E-Mail zum Beispiel zu sagen hier dieser Text ist jetzt.
Bolt geschrieben oder also in Fettdruck oder die Schriftart ist jetzt eine andere oder hier ist noch ein lustiges blinkendes gif ein Katzenbild eingebunden in die E-Mail.
Und das wird seit wir haben ich weiß nicht genau seit wann gemacht also hat.
Glaube ich angefangen mit Hotmail oder so ne Hotmail hat ja dieses HTML drin oder so wie dem auch sei es wird auf jeden Fall sehr lange schon gemacht dass man sich E-Mails zusenden kann und diese.
In HTML auch von dem von dem E-Mail Programm dargestellt.
Und interpretiert werden das hat eine Reihe also neben den schönen Vorteilen also pinke Schrift Comic Sans bunte Bildchen hat das verschiedene Nachteile.
Aus sicherheits perfektive primär einmal den das also nun das E-Mail Leseprogramm eigentlich ein komplette HTML Renderer ist und da lässt sich.
Kann man klassische Angriffe auch irgendwie noch zu recherchieren.
GAAP FER sehr langer Zeit dann auch immer das Problem das Outlook Express dann in die meinte ja lass uns auch direkt noch JavaScript uns zu melden lassen die wir dann ausführen was natürlich zu den entschiedenen Problem dann führte aber das lass mal kurz außen vor,
eines der Kernprobleme die die man jetzt die man jeden Tag sieht von.
Aktiven Inhalten oder von HTML Inhalten von in E-Mails ist ich schicke jemanden eine E-Mail.
Und Bette in diese E-Mail ein kleines unsichtbares Bild 1 welches aber auf einem Server liegt.
Also sowas wie hallo hier in der sowieso wieso und füge dann ein Bild ein und sage dieses Bild liegt unter was weiß ich www Linus Bindestrich neumann.de Slash Bild.
Und dann hau ich mir in der Regel in so weil ich ja nicht doof bin mal mir dann noch so ein kleines Fragezeichen dahinter und gib mir noch ein GET-Parameter mit den ich und bei jeder email dich Versende vergebe ich einen anderen.
Dieser getparameter was zur Folge hat dass in einem unsicheren Mailer wenn diese E-Mail geöffnet wird.
Dieses Bild nachgeladen wird und zwar von meinem Server und da ich in dieser e-Mail quasi ein für mich.
Zuordenbaren identifier an das Bild dran geheftet habe kann ich so z.b. feststellen dass die E-Mail geöffnet wurde.
Und von wem.
Genau weil ich mir gemerkt habe wem ich welchen identifier geschickt habe weiß ich von wem nennt sich Tracking Pixel.
So entscheidende Punkt dabei ist erstmal nur dass das geht ja dann schreibt einfach rein Spitze Klammer auf imgsrc gleich also Bildquelle gleich und schreibt dann da in HTML,
hatte typer Textlink hin und dann wird er in einem unsicheren Mailer zugegriffen.
Das ist so lange kein Problem wie.
Also es ist sowieso schon mein Problem ja es ist ohnehin ein Problem wenn man ebensolche wenn man das bei normalen E-Mail schon Anhalt weil es eben dieses ganze Tracking erlaubt wann eine E-Mail geöffnet wurde und so wird von Spammern,
gerne benutzt also HTML in E-Mails keine gute Idee.
Man kann daher dass in verschiedenen WLAN auch vollständig deaktivieren.
Haben E-Mails werden.
Häufig auch so Versand dass sie quasi multipath einmal den hatten Eltern schicken und einen nur Textteil.
Man kann in vielen,
soll ich ein E-Mail Programm dann z.b. auch ein Häkchen setzen externe reforce entladen oder nicht laden einige Male anmachen das auch inzwischen automatisch nicht mehr die Gemengelage ist da aber sehr undurchsichtig wo wir auch später noch zu.
Kommen werden.
Kurze Anmerkung weil dieses ganze HTML in E-Mail ist Evil Diskussion ja auch immer wieder Wellen schlägt.
Ich finde dass das hier vor allem ein Geburtsfehler ist ich habe eigentlich.
Ich finde eigentlich HTML in ihm eine tolle Idee weil es eine super Sache ist mal etwas strukturiert eine Mail zu schreiben als immer nur irgendwie in Texten.
Überschriften etc ist eigentlich alles super und man hätte eigentlich auch von Anfang an das mit den Bildern,
problemlos lösen können die mir einfach gesagt hat ja ihr könnt schon HTML und Bilder auch verwenden aber die Bilder werde natürlich nicht nachgeladen gibt hier keine Links die automatisch ausgewertet werden sollen wenn ihr Bilder haben wollt dann könnt ihr die.
Das sieht ja dass mein von vorne rein vor ich kann ja auch in eine normale Text male ein Bild reintun weil dann ist die halt,
in der Mail und nicht auf einem anderen Server und das hätte man halt auch bei HTML Locker so machen können dass man sagt okay ich kann es verlieren Imageshack machen aber ich referenziere halt nicht ein Bild auf dem anderen Server sollen eben die die in dieser Mail ist,
und dann wäre das nicht mehr das Problem gewesen und hätte quasi alles Gute von HTML gehabt ohne diesen Nachteil dieses konkrete noch.
Anderer Aspekt der arbeit finden.
Also das mit diesen Bildern auf jeden Fall mit dem mit externen Ressourcen also eine prinzipielle policy wäre auf jeden Fall sehr schön zu sein externen eben nicht egal was es ist,
du hast sehr sehr viele unterschiedliche Möglichkeiten dir so einen Rückkanal zu bauen du kannst auch z.b. einen ein Formular in HTML schreiben.
Und über CSS das dann so layouten dass du sagst egal wo jemand hinkriegt das Formular wird abgesendet und hast du auf diese Seite.
Auf diesem Weg einen Rückkanal also in HTML Rück Kanäle zu bauen ist eine sehr einfache,
Angelegenheit weil eben hatte Mary auch in seiner Spezifikation sehr weit gewachsen ist und immer mehr Canvas irgendwo mit externen Ressourcen und so zu tun hat.
Eine Option ist z.b. wenn man jetzt irgendwie eine,
Haus in application basierte Firewall hat z.b. die Mail einfach grundsätzlich alle anderen Verbindung zu verbieten das bei mir der Fall ja also ich sollte da noch irgendetwas rausfallen bei meinem,
bei meinem Ela was nicht,
das abholen oder das Senden von E-Mails an die Server die ich verwende ist dann sagt die Firewall einfach nur du darfst gar nicht ins Internet du darfst keine Verbindung zu Tor herstellen oder oder Webseiten aufrufen.
Aber das ist erstmal das Grundproblem so.
Vermesser gesagt okay wir können aktive Inhalte in HTML formulieren Sie sind mannigfach und sie können genutzt werden um Verbindungen zu externen Seiten herzustellen jetzt stelle man sich vor.
Wir würden eine E-Mail schreiben in der wir ganz am Anfang schreiben lade ein Bild.
Von folgende Seite HTTP Linus milfina man.de und dann kommt der gesamte Text der E-Mail und am Ende mache ich dieses Pack wieder zu das hätte zur Folge dass die HTML render engine den gesamten E-Mail Text.
Alfred Quest an mein Webserver schickt.
Das heißt man könnte so auch auf diesem Wege Inhalte von E-Mails extrahieren.
Einfach nur prinzipiell möglich hätte.
Grundsätzlich erstmal niemand ein Interesse dran der eine E-Mail sendet weil er ja wissen was in der E-Mail drin steht das heißt es gibt wenig Motivation das zu tun.
Es sei denn.
Jetzt kommen wir zum zweiten Teil des Angriffs es würde mir gelingen so etwas also diesen Rückkanal in eine E-Mail.
Rein zu schieben die verschlüsselt ist also der Zielzustand ist ich habe eine verschlüsselte E-Mail in der Hand.
Ich sorge dafür dass dein irgendeiner Stelle.
Dieser Rückkanal aufgemacht wird also Laden im Daimler bei dem Beispielbild lade ein Bild von folgender Seite und dieses Bild heißt.
Gesamter Inhalt der E-Mail Spitze Klammer zu.
Dann würde eben wenn ich das geschickt mache an der richtigen Stelle mache gelingt ist eben tatsächlich dass das passiert.
Und das ist quasi das was jetzt also das Ergebnis beim beim.
Bei der vier Personen soll am Ende sein dass der Mailer.
Diese E-Mail bekommen Sarah, hier der ist ein verschlüsselter Teil drin den entschlüsselt ich jetzt mal und das dann in diesen verschlüsselten Teil diese minimale Modifikation drin ist.
Oder,
vor dem verschlüsselten Teil diese minimale Modifikation schon drin ist die dazu führt dass dann der Mailer beim HTML interpretieren sagt jetzt lade ich diese externe sofort danach und diese externe das was ist der gesamte Inhalt der E-Mail,
und damit schickt er dir dann einen Server und der Server schickt was weiß ich den kannst dir dann so bauen dass du dir einfach den gesamten Inhalt auch wieder zurückschickt ja da sind so dass du das gar nicht siehst.
So und das darf aber natürlich nicht passieren dass dass das,
das Alters einer Angreiferin das gelingt so also wir haben,
nach lanex Teneriffa essen wir haben theoretisch können wir über das nach Laden externe Ressourcen auch Inhalte der E-Mail exfiltrieren das heißt wir dürfen nicht zulassen dass jemand und so etwas,
einbaut da die nächste Herausforderung in der angriffskette ist also schaffe ich es dass ich eine verschlüsselte E-Mail habe deren,
Inhalt ich nicht entschlüsseln kann wo ich aber trotzdem dafür sorgen kann das am Ende bei Mail aber Dead e-mail interpretiert.
Ich an der richtigen Stelle HTML-Tags eingebaut habe die am Ende wieder valide genutzt werden und da gibt es hier zwei Wege der eine.
Ist er nennt wird genannt direct Exfiltration.
Der funktioniert in s-mine bei verschiedenen mail client.
Und der nutzt muss also wirklich betrifft nur die E-Mail Clients denn die haben den.
Dem Problem der die haben das Problem dass sie multi-part message ist am Ende einfach wieder aneinander Pappen und du du du nimmst also quasi eine neue du hast eine existierende E-Mail die hast du abgefangen.
Schon zugestellt oder nicht zugestellt ist jetzt eigentlich egal du hast du bist im Besitz einer validen vollständig verschlüsselten E-Mail von einem Absender an eine Empfängerin jetzt nimmst du diese E-Mail und baust daraus,
eine multipath E-Mail wurde im ersten Teil im Prinzip diesen Öffnen dieses offene Imageshack macht.
In zwei und zwei packst du einfach die verschlüsselte E-Mail rein die wird der kleinen nämlich entschlüsseln und in dritten Teil masturbiert dustec wieder zu mit der spitzen Klammer was dann passiert du schickst diese du stellst diese E-Mail an das Opfer zu.
Der Rechner entschlüsselt den zweiten Teil der multipath e-mail baut diese drei Teile wieder aneinander.
Und schick daraus dann am Ende eine valide E-Mail durch und Ränder die in HTML.
Das heißt du hast dann einfach nur vor den verschlüsselten Teil den der Mail aber automatisch entschlüsselt bei dir drin steht hier beginnt der verschlüsselte Teil hier endet der verschlüsselte teil und der Meller sagt ja alles klar das muss ich hier das kenne ich das muss ich entschlüsseln und dann,
das geht quasi automatisch du sendest diese Mail an eben einen der Betroffenen Mail-Client und das wird einfach passieren.
Was ist eigentlich der korrekte Sound für ich schüttel meinen Kopf vor entgeisterung.
Weiß ich nicht.
Beginn von will ich jetzt gerne ein.
So aber bis zu dieser Stelle der. So also wunderschöner wunderschöne Idee für einen Angriff.
Wichtiger Hinweis betrifft laut der Forschungsgruppe die das veröffentlicht hat Apple Mail iOS Mail und Mozilla,
Thunderbird,
und ist aber ein eindeutig eine Schwachstelle dieser Mail clients ja wir haben hier nichts das ist nicht eine Schwäche von Essenheim das ist keine Schwäche in der Verschlüsselung die wurde auch nicht geknackt das ist einfach nur ein,
eine schwerwiegende Schwachstelle in diesen Merklein jetzt gibt es den.
Und zwar und zwar auch so eine so eine blöde weil wenn man kurz vor nachdenkt ist klar die Mail besteht aus drei Teilen,
jeder Teil muss für sich behandelt werden das heißt I wäre quasi unvollständiges HTML III wäre unvollständiges HTML und nur so sollte es angezeigt werden und dazwischen halt einfach der Textblock aber,
erst alles zu entschlüsseln und dann noch mal komplett kombiniert zu interpretieren das ist hier der Fehler der an der Stelle greift.
Jetzt gibt's noch einen zweiten Angriff der BS maimunki JP funktioniert und das ist der CD ccfb Gadget Angriff okay ich versuche jetzt ein bisschen.
Einfach zu machen.
Verschissen kann man sich immer so vorstellen wie es gibt den den Plaintext das ist was aus Einsen und Nullen bestehendes am Ende auf der niedrigsten Ebene und es wird,
in der Regel gemischt mit einem ebenfalls aus Einsen und Nullen von Zufall nicht zu unterscheidenden Datenstrom.
Mit der Operation ixor.
Lyxor führt dazu dass im Prinzip die Einsen und Nullen also das man hat einmal den plantex und einer hat man diesen Pfeifer Stream und diese beiden Sachen werden einfach miteinander.
Verein im vereinfachten Sinne gemischt so dass man nicht mehr weiß was von beidem was war.
Vereinfache ähnlich wie damals bei Spectre und so weiter ich vereinfache das ein bisschen entscheidend ist wenn man.
Einen geringen Teil der entschlüsseln den Daten kennt kann man in diesen.
Pfeiffer text prinzipiell gewünschte Inhalte einfügen.
Also Grundbedingung ist ich weiß ein Teil dessen der in der nachricht drinsteht und wenn ich das nicht weiß dann funktioniert dieser Angriff auch nicht.
Häufig.
Also dass man weiß was ein in einem Teil der nachricht drinsteht ist sehr häufig der Angriffsvektor mit dem am Ende Kryptosysteme ausgewählt wer nicht glaubst du das auch mal so eine Cre Folge zur Enigma gehabt.
Nee weniger nicht.
Lass mich bei ich dachte ich hätte das bei dir im Podcast gehört also die Enigma die Verschlüsselungsmaschine die die Nazis benutzt haben hatte im Prinzip zwei Fehler der eine war dass sie.
Das nicht zwei aufeinander Buchstaben folgende ciphertext Buchstaben die gleichen sein konnten das war die mechanische Einschränkung.
Und das was ihn aber am Ende geholfen hat ist dass die Nazis ihre Mails immer gleich begonnen haben Ihre verschlüsselten Nachrichten nämlich mit High Heels.
Altlayer genau.
Damit hattest du.
So und.
Diese Obsession Etsy Dixi Kassel Thomann.
Und das damit hattest du quasi dass das mal ausreichend ich meine das war natürlich nicht so einfach das dann zu knacken und das ist eine ganz spannende Aufgaben die kann gerne mal recherchieren entscheidend war dadurch dass die immer wussten dass sie von diesem kleinen,
known Plaintext konnten sie dann irgendwann in Kombination mit dieser anderen Stell dass sie eine Eigenschaft über den.
Über die Mechanik des Gerätes kannten konnten sie eben letztendlich wann sie dann in der Lage.
Ihren Brute-Force-Angriff den sie immer noch machen mussten in ein mathematisch überschaubaren Raum.
Zu überführen wo sie wussten welche verschiedenen Kombination sie überhaupt noch ausprobieren mussten.
Aber das waren halt extrem viel weniger.
Okay das darf ein kleiner Exkurs zu viele Angriffe funktionieren über eben über bekannten Plaintext weil man sich daraus eben dann den Datenstrom quasi rekonstruieren kann und dann.
Auch eigene Datenblöcke einfügen kann die dann immer wieder auch unsinnige Teile ergeben aber es,
gelingt dafür zu sorgen dass diese unsinnigen Teile wieder ignoriert werden weil ihr hier genug Markup languages genutzt werden und weil die HTML Parser traditionell relativ gutmütig sind.
Kann man also.
Oder ist es halt schon seit sehr langer Zeit bekannt dass ich in so ein Pfeifer Stream als externer Angreifer.
Inhalte Insekten kann wenn ich Inhalte kenne jetzt ist es dummerweise so dass diese ganzen verschlüsselten Nachrichten.
Insbesondere auch dank dieses HTML sehr häufig.
Standard an Standard Inhalte haben nämlich so eine Apple Mail nachricht die beginnt erstmal mit dem riesigen Barum ja was da an HTML alles kommt generate a Apple Mail hasse alles nicht gesehen CSS und so weiter und da das reicht halt schon.
Wenn man wenn man diese Inhalte kennt oder zbs meine E-Mails fangen in der Regel an mit Content time multipath Flashpoint das reicht halt schon dass du einen vollen,
Block,
in der Chiffre hast von der du den Plaintext kennst und dann entsprechende anschließende plantex Blöcke bauen kann die dann irgendwann.
Quasi zurückgegeben würden als Teil dieser Schiffe.
Und signature Cindy an der Stelle eigentlich auch eine Gefährdung ne.
Genau ja sowas wie bitte drucken Sie diese.
Bitte drucken Sie diese diese Mail nicht aus blablabla Rechtsbelehrung irgendwie 5 kg bei immer wieder derselbe Text jeder Mail ich meine diese Mails werden sowieso unverschlüsselt verschickt aber an sich keine.
Also dass in einer echten Welt würdest du den Angriffe im Prinzip beginnen wenn du einmal eine unverschlüsselte Mail von einer von deiner Zielpersonen bekommen.
Obwohl das 80% der Mail ausmacht ne ja hallo klar machen wir so und dann erstmal so 80 Kilobyte Standard lemak.
Genau also gegeben ist das dass du dass das gut in gut informierten Angreifer eben kleine Teile mit hoher Sicherheit bekannt sind.
An welcher Stelle die stehen und bei erstmal im ist das so dass der,
dass dieser das auch keine weitere Modifikation annehmen annehmen unverschlüsselten text stattfindet so dass du mit sehr hoher Sicherheit sogar sein kann an diesem beisteht.
Multipartfile da beginnt das ja und dann kannst Du eben daran aufbauen inject ist ein bisschen was dann eben am Ende wieder rauskommt als dieses HTML Image Decoder einer von vielen anderen Kanälen.
Jetzt ist er so dass das nicht dass das kein Geheimnis ist die Diskussion darüber dass das eben bei diesem Chiffren möglich ist die wurde irgendwie März 99.
Geführt und Snoopy Gigi hat irgendwie einen Monat später eine Gegenmaßnahme,
ausgeheult,
und im Sommer 2000 wurde die eben ist sie dann halt auch also wurde sie ausgeräumt entwickelt wurde sie Monat später ausgerollt wurde sie 2000 im Sommer 2000 das ist der modification,
detection code kurz MDC.
Kann man sich im Prinzip so vorstellen dass du eine Prüfsumme immer weiter fürs über deine blocke und wenn diese Prüfsumme an irgendeiner Stelle nicht mehr stimmt dann sagst du eben okay.
Diese Nachricht wurde offenbar manipuliert Warnung so und.
Bye bye ist mein funktioniert im Prinzip ähnlich so also das Problem ist eigentlich dass die Verschlüsse die Entschlüsselung ohne Authentifizierung statt.
Finden kann es meinem hat das überhaupt nicht so eine Authentifizierung TTP hat das.
Theoretisch die ist aber in der Praxis oft.
Nutzlos weil die Pipi library quasi dir trotzdem.
Den Inhalt zurückgibt und dir dazu die Warnung gibt Achtung hier ist die Prüfung fehlgeschlagen oder es gab gar keinen MDC.
Eine Nachricht ohne NDC verschicken und jetzt müsstest du eigentlich.
Also die sichere Variante das zu tun wäre wenn Pipi einfach wenn dieses MDC nicht vorhanden ist oder fehlschlägt sich vollständig weigert diese Nachricht.
Überhaupt auszugeben also sofort achso nein stimmt nicht kaputt ich sag da nichts zu ich nehme das nicht auseinander ich gebe dir auch nicht zurück was hier ist ich beende das.
So wie es mit https zunehmend umgegangen wird wenn da was nicht stimmt.
Richtig so und jetzt sagt sie es haben die and standard aber so geschrieben dass Pipi im Prinzip sagt Warnung.
Hier das ist nicht authentifiziert oder die Prüfung ist fehlgeschlagen.
Pass bitte auf liebe liebe Nutzerin und in der Regel kommen cipiripi eben mit dem ella.
Und jetzt ist die Schwachstelle in Kombination das im in dem Standard eigentlich im Prinzip drinsteht der Mailer sollte.
Das was er dann zurück kriegt nicht mehr weiter interpretieren.
Was da natürlich drin stehen sollten im Standard ist darf das nicht mehr interpretieren und jetzt schubsen sie jetzt ist natürlich so dass das Problem.
Also die der fix müsste auf mehreren Ebenen stattfinden er muss ausgeräumt werden und dann hast du eben dieses unschöne Zusammenspiel von PIP libraries die irgendwie mal irgendwo rein kompiliert wurden die oder die irgendwie als Agent irgendwo laufen du hast dann halt eine riesige Matrix an Kombination aus Mail an,
und Pipi Versionen und E-Mail Akins und hasse alles nicht gesehen die dazu führen dass eben dass es in vielen corner cases,
mit diesem Angriff möglich ist den den Plaintext einer Nachricht zu exfiltrieren.
Kleine Randbemerkung noch bei Pipi ist es im Standard dass die außerdem die komplette Nachricht bevor sie die verschlüsseln einmal komprimieren also.
Weiß ich diese oder irgendwas darüber scheuchen das heißt das was sie Dir schicken ist noch dazu eine komprimierte mehr das macht es noch einmal komplizierter.
Nicht aber unmöglich diese Sachen da rein zu injecten weil du musst quasi na du musst einerseits wissen wie der Kompression Stream aussieht muss in diesem Kompressionsriemen valide etwas rein bauen und dann das muss dann und dann quasi eine Ebene mehr.
Was jetzt bei den Angreifern dazu geführt hat dass sie sagten das ist uns im Schnitt ungefähr bei jedem dritten Mal gelungen.
Das wäre sie diese zweite Ebene noch drinne das kann man also nicht als eine wirksame Schutzmaßnahme bezeichnen macht es den Angreifern aber schwerer nur bei Verschlüsselung geht's nicht um schwerer es geht darum.
Geht gar nicht und das ist das ist das was hier der Fall ist also.
Zusammengefasst eine wunderschöne in echt spannender Angriff der hier kombiniert wurde aus mehreren.
Auf mehreren Schwachstellen ja wie das so häufig ist bei den schönen Angriffen von einem Forscherteam der.
Universität Münster oder University of Applied Sciences habe ich Fachhochschule ne.
Ruhr Uni Bochum und eleven das ist in Belgien.
Lange Liste an Autoren Damian potap Niag Christian Dreesen Jens Müller Fabian Ising Sebastian Schinzel Simon Friedberger Jura Summe rovski.
Und Jörg schwenke.
Großer Respekt schöner Angriff gar keine Frage aber es ist leider über zum Glück wirklich nicht der Untergang der Welt,
und dass wir hier von der IFF reagiert wurde die dann also schrieb,
installiert jetzt sofort Europe JP und dann irgendwie vier Anleitung oder was dazu publiziert hat für die gängigen Dinger da irgendwie Push-Nachricht Forscher knacken E-Mail-Verschlüsselung verschlüsselte E-Mails sind nicht sicher,
das ist schon ein kleines bisschen über den.
Wie weit übers Ziel hinausgeschossen sag mal eine Meldung wie.
Schwere Sicherheitslücke erfordert grundlegendes Update bei PIP hätte sich wahrscheinlich dann auch nicht so gut geklickt wäre aber eben sehr viel.
Wahrheitsgetreue.
Wahrheitsgetreue gewesen so gleichzeitig schlagen natürlich im im Herzen der Journalisten so etwas veröffentlichen,
in der Brust auch zwei Herzen die wollen natürlich erstens die Aufmerksamkeit für Ihre Meldung haben und die können natürlich auch argumentieren wir müssen hier warnen vor der Verwendung es handelt sich um eine schwerwiegende Sicherheitslücke die eben Updates erfordert,
dann gibt's noch weitere Zankereien irgendwie zwischen den Entwicklern der verschiedenen Plugins die teilweise sich eben,
böswillig da interpretiert und behandelt sehen da will ich jetzt gar nicht in im Detail drauf eingehen,
es wird auf jeden Fall ein größeres Problem alles wird längere Zeit dauern bis das wirklich definitiv aus der Welt ist insofern.
Sind jetzt für die naheliegenden sixes also keine automatische decryption zu haben sollte man eh nicht haben und E-Mails nicht HTML zur ändern kann man in vielen Mail an auch tatsächlich deaktivieren man kann.
Das Nachladen externer Inhalte deaktivieren bei bestimmten Mail an auch da Vorsicht angesagt weil es nicht alle korrekt implementiert haben man kann das machen was ich habe ich schon seit Jahren also im Prinzip einfach den Mailer.
Mit einer application Firewall daran hindern jedweder Art von Verbindung herzustellen die nicht das Abholen von E-Mails ist.
Auch da könnte es unter Umständen noch irgendein blöden Rückkanal geben dann den ich jetzt nicht gedacht habe also letztendlich natürlich.
Das muss rausgepatcht werden das muss geupdatet werden wie bei vielen anderen Schwachstellen auch,
jetzt irgendwie große die Installationsanleitung zu veröffentlichen und zu sagen das ist jetzt ein für allemal Tod wie es auch einige.
US-amerikanische Autographen dann da jetzt irgendwie in die Welt schreien ist ein bisschen übers Ziel hinausgeschossen.
Insbesondere ist amüsant dass die IFF ja dann ihr wie groß zur Verwendung von Cygnet.
Fitness Notsignal Nutzen der Schreiner ihr seid seit Ewigkeiten hin und her.
Und Zeichen Tag erscheint Zufall zu sein aber am gleichen Tag wird eine,
genauso ein HTML Tag injection im Signal Desktop Client veröffentlicht ja von Ivan.
Maburaho der irgendwie mit einem Kollegen Sicherheitsforscher zu sein der irgendwie mit einem Kollegen über eine XSS also eben auch über eine html Tech injection,
schrieb die REWE Quadrate gemeinsam erforschte und sein Kollege schickt sie ihn im Prinzip das zu initiierende.
XFS und das müsste dann eben auch in seinem Signal Client außer das heißt die gleiche Schwachstelle.
Nämlich man kann arbiträres HTML sogar mit aktiven Inhalten.
Insekten zu stellen und dadurch quasi Nachrichten exfiltrieren zumal es hier dann noch darum geht dass der.
Davon hier in iframe bauen kann und damit irgendwas was ich eine Datei schicken kann die ausgeführt wird und so weiter.
Exakt die gleiche Kategorie Schwachstelle.
Haben wir hier auch ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ob die auch ein Angreifer in eine Nachricht.
Einbauen könnte die.
Die er nicht selber verschlüsselt hat aber wir haben also auch die gleiche Kategorie das eben am Ende hatte Melkerin datiert.
Ist doch klar was soll getan werden muss immer Single muss jetzt auch noch überall deinstalliert werden.
Bitte also bitte keine verschlüsselte Nachrichten schicken sie könnten entschlüsselt werden na ja.
Das ist natürlich nicht was wir sagen sagen okay es gibt hier Fehler in E-Mail Clients in der Art und Weise wie sie.
Mit diesen Inhalten umgehen falsche Reihenfolge von Rindern falsche Annahmen es gibt auch,
Fehler in Bibliotheken von Krypto Software die grundsätzlich schon mal nicht genug ausschließt.
Das hätte auch geholfen ja es müssen jetzt noch für Updates erscheinen um diese Lücken zu schließen es ist auch davon auszugehen dass das mittelfristig geschehen wird auf manchen Plattform schneller auf manchen Plattform langsamer,
ja das ist alles nicht gut aber die eigentliche Crypto ist sie nicht gebrochen.
Far from it und von daher wäre es ganz gut wenn da vielleicht mal ein bisschen Dampf rausgenommen wird hasse ich jetzt.
Und wer auch immer diesen Angriff an euch durchführen wollte.
Müsste vorher schon mal überhaupt eine dieser verschlüsselten E-Mails in den Fingern gehabt haben also ich es geht ja nur ich kann das ja nur machen wenn ich diese eine verschlüsselte E-Mail.
In meine Finger bekommen habe und entweder auf dem Versandweg manipuliere oder sie nachher noch mal Schicke na also.
Wobei mir aber sagen muss das ist normal bei E-Mail eben auch leichter als bei allen anderen System.
Richtig und das ist ja auch genau das wogegen Pipi schützen soll ja aber heißt das für mich.
Oder fährt irgendwo in die wenigen PIP User dir draußen irgendwo sitzen.
Das jetzt so eine unmittelbare Gefahr droht das sofort das pipipi deinstalliert werden muss.
Denke nicht so wenn jetzt irgendwie Julian Assange in der in der in der in seiner ecuadorianischen Botschaft sitzt und.
Und irgendwie nails,
jetzt kriegt der sollte natürlich vorsichtig sein dass ich dahinter nicht an derartiger Angriff verbirgt der kann natürlich dann z.b. so etwas machen Sie die automatische die Püppchen aus haben ich würde,
von ihm eigentlich erwarten dass er ohnehin einen Mailer nutzt der nicht HTML oder aktive Inhalte Renate also die ganze haben ja sich auch irgendwie sehr herzlich ins Fäustchen gelacht als jetzt diese diese Angriffe.
Veröffentlicht wurden.
Ich halte die unmittelbare Gefahr für die Bevölkerung an dieser Stelle erstmal noch für relativ gering.
Also ihr könnt wieder unter den Sofa zwischen Erfurt kriechen der Untergang der elektronischen Welt ist weiter hinten verschoben und unklar wann der stattfindet.
Wir mal beim schönen Angriff hier und da muss man einfach mal sagen ist wichtig dass solche Angriffe entdeckt werden es ist wichtig dass auf die hingewiesen wird es ist wichtig dass die beseitigt werden.
Ich will jetzt mich nicht mehr lange darüber auslassen der sich das ohnehin mit.
Zunehmende mark-wohnen betrachte das irgendwie.
Inzwischen wohl üblich ist dass man sich zu seinem Schwachstellen irgendwie einen Namen macht eine Domain registriert.
Logo.
Logo hatten embargo hat um dann schon mal drei Tage vorher zu trommeln dann einen Medienpartner hat der Diesel Schwachstellen exclusive veröffentlicht ich weiß nicht wie lange das jetzt noch.
Auch funktioniert ich kann da alle Player verstehen ja.
Kann ich schon alliston verstehen die sagen hier da haben wir Klicks und die auch sicher auskehren Motiven arbeiten und sagen dann müssen die Menschen vor gewarnt werden ich kann die Forscher verstehen die sagen ich will nicht dass meine ganze Arbeit finden für ein Schlunz ist sondern ich will das,
darauf aufmerksam gemacht wird um hier immer diese Updates zu pushen gleichzeitig muss man aber sagen so na ja in diesem Pipi Bereich der Wahrheit bei weitem noch nicht alle alle Stellen g****** und da gibt's dann eben auch.
Stellt man sich immer auf die Frage ob dann eine Veröffentlichung jetzt notwendig war oder nicht ob diese Frage gibt immer drei Antworten,
die einen sagen sonst fixen sie es nie die anderen sagen nee bringt Leute in Gefahr das ist alles sind alles Detail Diskussion ja aber so diese.
Diese hyperventilieren wir nehmen das Hyperventilation die jetzt bei bestimmten Schwachstellen stattfindet ist nicht immer,
Handy korreliert nicht immer mit dem tatsächlichen akuten Bedrohung Szenario was entstanden ist und das ist Leben sondern vielmehr damit sie.
Wie spannend wie gut der das Forscherteam sich seine Medienpartner ausgesucht hat und das kann eben auch mittelfristig nicht.
Dazu führen dass wir dass wir hier eben vernünftig Vorgehen so da muss man sich mal.
Genau damit auseinandersetzen weil eben diese Aufmerksamkeit dadurch eben auch nicht mehr gleichverteilt ist und viel Aufmerksamkeit eben.
Dadurch bestimmt wird dass es was was ich bei ein paar Tage vor Verschlüsselung also das.
Hätte nicht sein müssen.
Junge Junge das war ein bisschen übers Ziel hinaus.
Ja wären wenn wir hier hyperventilieren und vor und unsere großen ahren ausrufen dann hat man das natürlich abzunehmen.
Ja natürlich.
Also sofort oder die T-Shirt an.
Ja ja.
Aufgedeckt werden musste auch einen Vorgang der jetzt wohl sich in der Türkei abgespielt hat weil jetzt ist etwas übertrieben schon eine Weile her vor.
Einigen Monaten ist jetzt gesagt genau vom Jahr,
gab's diesen relativ viel beachteten Fußmarsch NSDAP Oppositionspolitiker,
das Name ich nicht richtig aussprechen kann weil ich der türkischen Schreibung und Sprache nicht mächtig bin so etwas wie Kemal Kilicdaroglu.
Würde ich jetzt mal so vor mich hin Raunen der hat ja relativ die Öffentlichkeit gefunden und auch in sozialen Medien,
Anklang gefunden hat bisher noch keine tiefgreifenden Veränderungen in der Türkei nach sich gezogen aber nichtsdestotrotz sicherlich ein,
wichtiger Teil des bürgerlichen Widerstands oder an der Stelle eben auch mal Widerstand der.
Aus dem Polizist doublemint an herauskam.
Nun gibt es ein Bericht von der Bürgerrechts Gruppe Access nach das ist wohl im Zusammenhang mit dieser ganzen Aktion.
Den Einsatz das dauert der Einsatz einer Software für Smartphones und zwar.
Wurden dafür auf Twitter wo man die Hashtags gekapert aufhörte eine Seite verwiesen die offenbar Informationen zum Fortgang dieses Fußmarsch hat und die vielleicht auch gehabt hat das weiß ich jetzt nicht,
aber nebenbei auch noch eine.
Android App bewarb die man sich doch mal installieren solle um sozusagen weiter hier die Muse Flow folgen zu können und siehe da diese App,
war,
dann mit einer entsprechenden Software infizierte also eine Trojaner Software und um welche Software könnte es sich hier wohl handeln alter Bekannter das ganze kommt.
Ostdeutschland wir sind ein Scheinhardt also.
Die Firma finfisher haben wir ja schon öfter behandelt und oft auch diskutiert das Tieren treiben nämlich,
was ist auf der herauszubringen die explizit Bekannte oder eben rum bekannte Sicherheitslücken auf Smartphones und anderen Systemen ausnutzt und dann entsprechend Überwachung Software zu installieren auf Desktop Sound eben auch auf Smartphones.
Sieht so also aus als ob diese Software unter dem Titel finspy wohlbekannt hier zum Einsatz kam die daneben auf diesem Telefon live mit hören und mitlesen konnte was auf diesem Telefon.
Passiert wäre das ja auch von paar Sendung mit Facebook und so weiter geht sicherlich um das Auslesen von SMS und dem notieren von Telefonnummern die gewählt wurden hinaus.
Ja und das hat.
Stattgefunden jetzt ist er sich die Frage wer war das lässt sich natürlich schwer sagen man könnte argumentieren das Interesse an dem ausspionieren eine Oppositionspartei oder der Sprinter dadurch motivierten,
Bevölkerungsgruppe möge wohl im Wesentlichen im Interesse der Regierungspartei sein aber das ist jetzt erstmal noch kein,
du weißt genau seid ihr das ganze auch,
von außen kommen können Mann muss ich vor einem fragen wie es diese Software in die Türkei gekommen also wenn sie dort wirklich professionell eingesetzt wurde auf welchem wegen weil,
eigentlich dürfte diese Software nach den geltenden Regularien nicht an die Türkei offiziell ausgeliefert werden das verbietet die aktuelle Gesetzeslage und ja da ist derzeit noch.
Unklarheit.
Also muss er,
sagen sie finfisher sagt nach eigenen eigenen Auskünften sie verkaufen ausschließlich an Strafverfolgungsbehörden und Geheimdienste zum rechtmäßigen Einsatz gegen,
Terror und Gewaltverbrechen.
Terror.
Das ist so dann zweitens,
wir haben Ferien nicht mit ihm gezielten Angriff zu tun sondern das einfach nur authoring hole Angriff dass wir in welche Hashtags Fluten und sagen ladet euch mal alle alle die ihn die Interesse an diesen,
Fussmarsch haben wir das stattfindet ladet euch mal bitte diese App runter das heißt du hast am Ende nicht zu beziffern der Anzahl Personen.
Die sich diese App installieren die dann aber irgendwie mit dem.
Wirklich mit dem relativ mit dem bösesten Smartphone mit dem bösesten staatlichen Smartphone Trojaner infiziert sind dem anderen vikend,
und finfisher das sind die die auch in Deutschland vom BKA genutzt werden und die da diese lange gebraucht haben bis sie da irgendwann mal ein Vertrag mit dem BKA machen konnten weil ihre Software nämlich so viel mehr kann.
Als als das was sie.
Den anderen Unrechts Regime verkaufen dürften das heißt der größte Teil der in Arbeit war das Ding so einzuschränken.
Dass es brauchbar ist für für die für den deutschen.
Für die für die Verwendung in der Heimat ja,
wo muss noch ein bisschen strengere Einschränkungen gibt insbesondere ich auch durch die vielen verschiedenen Verfahren die Bürgerrechts Gruppen unter an der Chaos Computer Club seit über einem Jahrzehnt gegen dieses Vorhaben anstrengen.
Woher sind die sich so sicher dass es sich um finfisher handelt es gibt ältere Version von von Zins bei Mobile.de liegt sind das die liegen vor die hat man so.
Und diese da sieht man eben was ich Installationsroutine und z.b. auch irgendwie Back-End Kommunikation oder auch die Wege wie Sie.
Wie sieht er auf SMS zugreifen und so weiter herunter in diesem neuen Tempel waren eben vieles davon gleich,
wo man jetzt natürlich sagen könnte na ja okay das hat ja vielleicht auch einfach eine da ist irgendwie wenn es Android,
Dinge sind kannst du eben diese apk Spa kannst du auch Teile einfach wieder verwenden muss sie nicht neu schreiben die kannst du irgendwie,
das ist ja eher so dieser hat dieser dahlweg Java-VM Code den du einfach auch relativ einfach wieder auseinandernehmen und wiederverwenden kannst.
Es waren aber hier auch die Teile gleich.
Zu den du am anderen Ende war fast nämlich z.b. die Kommunikation zu dem command and control Server und du würdest jetzt vielleicht irgendwie Ostwind bei Mobile den BZ dem den Teil klauen wieder die sms mitliest weil dann brauchst du nicht mehr selber bauen.
Wenn du arbeitshandy ausgerechnet den Teil Klaus der die Kommunikation mit dem command and control Server baut dann musst du dir auf der anderen Seite den gleichen, in control Server hinbauen.
Ja also wenn solche Teile verwendet werden die prezid wieder mit anderen teilen Interface in die ein anderer Angreifer oder eine andere Angreiferin an der Stelle.
In gleicher Form Annemarie implementieren müsste.
Dann ist das der Hinweis schon sehr sehr stark dass es sich hierbei eben um eine neue Generation von finspy handelt.
So und das ist.
Ja vielen Dank WKA dass wir ne dass wir dieses Land dass wir auch dieses Unternehmen fördern die hier offenbar mit.
Also Demokratur wie der Türkei zusammenarbeiten und sich da sogar für watering-hole-angriffe hergeben also einfach mal so machen Schüsse in die.
In die Menge der Menschen die offenbar gerade Interesse an einer Protestbewegung haben dass es sehr gut dass ihr da den Terror und den Gewaltverbrechen so allein halt bietet.
Schön dass das BKA mit solchen lupenreinen Demokraten zusammenarbeitet und auch schön dass unsere,
Export Restriktionen so gut funktionieren Bundeswirtschaftsministerium hatten wurde nämlich angefragt und hat gesagt er hat in den vergangenen Jahren überhaupt keine Export Lizenzen.
Mehr erteilt ja finfisher wurde natürlich gefragt ob sie achso na dann wurde sie noch gefragt ob finfisher jemals eine Lizenz beantragt habe und ob die oder ob sie verweigert wurde wurde nicht beantwortet.
Ja da wissen wir mit welchen Leuten wir hier zusammen arbeiten und das ist ja auch nicht das erste Mal also dass das find' bei in Unrechtsregime.
Im Nahen Osten zum Einsatz kommt ist relativ kalter Kaffee und es fehlen irgendwie noch so die Beispiel Länder wo das mal nicht.
Irgendwann so eine Demokratur war mit Andy die ihren Kram da verkauft haben das Umgehen von Export Restriktionen machen die natürlich in der Regel durch durch einfach firmenneugründung in den in den Südstaaten.
Also Software Refraktion Export Restriktionen auf Software sind schwierige Angelegenheit ja und wenn eben.
Wenn du da irgendwie eine Briefkastenfirma hast die dann vielleicht am Ende die die Software Rechte hat und so und irgendwie da und da sitzt dann kannst du das natürlich sehr sehr schnell umgehen und das scheint würde ich war hier hypothetisch.
Sagen scheint hier auch der Fall gewesen zu sein.
Gut aber die Mobilfunknetze haben wir auch in Deutschland große Attraktivität auf die Behörden.
Till auch in Berlin hat mir auch schon öfter darüber berichtet dass er hier extrem populär ist die Funkzellenabfrage.
Berlin wo die Berliner Polizei als gibt's nicht nur in Berlin gibt es ihren anderen Städten und Ländern Berlin ist es auch.
Gut im Einsatz wobei sie die Polizei die Möglichkeit hat wenn es ihr angemessen erscheint sondern eine Funkzellenabfrage vorzunehmen.
Um einfach dann von dem Mobilfunkbetreiber Informationen zu bekommen Wer ist denn eigentlich zu diesem Zeitpunkt oder.
Facefull wenn die Daten halt noch verfügbar sind eben auch zu einem früheren Zeitpunkt an einem bestimmten Funkzelle mit seinem mobiltelefon.
Eingebucht.
Und nicht nur eingebucht sein im Prinzip auch welche Aktivität dort ist also ob dort auch telefoniert wird angerufen wird man SMS versendet oder ob Datenkommunikation vorgenommen wird.
Ja jetzt gab es eine Anfrage.
Jedes Jahr.
Also die die da gibt es jetzt schon seit mehreren Jahren immer die Statistiken drüber die dann von netzpolitik.org verwertet werden die da gibt's quasi so ein Bericht ich weiß nicht mal den überhaupt noch,
Anfragen muss oder der meine Kleine Anfrage kommt oder ob der so so schon veröffentlicht wird.
Aber hier bei bei netzpolitik.org wurde das sehr schön aufbereitet die haben halt ne.
Simon sebinger hat das gemacht hat er drinne Berlin Karte aufgeschlüsselt nach Bezirken und dann irgendwie anhand der anhand der Anzahl.
Wie oft in den verschiedenen Bezirken solche Funkzellenabfrage stattgefunden haben das mal visualisiert sehr schöne.
Arbeit und der schaut das auch im Vergleich an nämlich er hat die Zahlen ab 2014 bei der 2014 die anzahl der Verfahren und seit 2015 auch die anzahl der Funkzellenabfrage.
Und das ist 2000 also 2015 man 327 2016 Bands 491 und 2017 Bands 400,
74 man könnte also sagen die Zahl der Funkzellenabfrage stagniert.
An in Berlin aber mit 474 Funkzellenabfrage bist du immer noch bei mehr als einer am Tag.
Das ist wirklich nicht irgendwie so eine so eine Sache die im im äußersten Fall mal gemacht wird wann ist der absolute Regel Maßnahme die ja dazu geführt hat dass im Rahmen dieser.
Nur die 174 Funkzellenabfrage 2017 die Berliner Polizei Zugriff auf 59000000,
Verkehrsdaten Sätze bekommen hat in 2222 Fällen haben sie dann sich für bestimmte.
Insis interessiert und danach dann die die die in die Inhaber der Nummer auch noch identifiziert das ist schon.
Echt einfach mal ein alltägliches Ermittlungs Instrument was routinemäßig eingesetzt wird weder.
Mit der Simon hier auch korrekt schreibt.
Aber immerhin rückläufig ist ja auch schon mal was.
20 weniger.
Ich freue mich nur was in dem gemütlichen Stadtteil Bridge eigentlich so Spannendes passiert.
Ja weiß ich auch nicht da er soll da müssen wir noch mal müssen wir noch mal fragen schreibt er das auch erst so halbwegs unkommentiert das da irgendwie in in Pritzier wieso eine Hotspot war.
13 verschiedene Ermittlungsverfahren.
Wird hier rund um die Metaebene nur dreimal was statt.
Ja quasi nix ne.
Da auch schon der totale Hotspot alle Bezirke um uns herum also alle Postleitzahlen danach ist er hier aufgeschlüsselt nicht nach Bezirken alle Postleitzahlen Warum haben nur.
Eine Anfrage alten also offensichtlich sitze ich hier schon in so ein Hotspot.
Also sagen die umfangreichste Funkzellenabfrage aus dem letzten Jahr fand zwischen den 16 und 19. Juni in der Berliner Innenstadt dauert Stadt dauerte 60 Stunden,
und da wurden 315000 Handynummern Gegner ins Raster so.
Das aber jetzt nicht dabei weswegen Ausfuhrbescheinigung.
Doch wollte nie irgendeinen Fall von Bandendiebstahl aufklären.
Türkei.
Und eigentlich.
Untersteht der auch Apsis Katana.
Verfall nicht also wenn du so viel Heu hast dann wird es halt schwer mit der Nadel ne.
Wobei das natürlich jetzt ein gutes Beispiel ist für den Rückhalt einer formulieren eine nachvollziehbare Anwendung dieser.
Also der Klassiker ist ja der dieser Autoanzünder den sie.
In der EM in Berlin ja einige Zeit da Autos angezündet hat den haben sie am Ende darüber bekommen ja der hat einfach jedes mal wenn du irgendwann wenn wir dein Auto geleuchtet hat haben sie eine Funkzellenabfrage gemacht und dann hatten sie den nach drei viermal er weil.
Also die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass da jemand zur gleichen Zeit am gleichen Ort ist ist eben sehr unwahrscheinlich und dann ist am Ende noch durch irgendeine Videoüberwachung gerannt Wahrnehmung U-Bahn U-Bahnhof und dann hatten sie so.
Das andere Beispiel ist aber der diese Demonstration in Dresden.
Wo sie einfach mal von der Demonstration Funkzellenabfrage gemacht haben Überstunden und am Ende alle Demonstrierenden dort erfasst haben.
Da gibt's ja nen vorsichtigen unterschied so die es gibt eine Benachrichtigungspflicht eigentlich,
so dass sie nämlich das gesetzlich müssten dass sie also wenn jemand wenn du also in einer Funktion Abfrage erfasst wurde dann müsstest du eigentlich darüber in Kenntnis gesetzt werden.
Und das passiert aber nicht.
So laut Gesetz schreibt jemanden müssen Betroffene über die Erfassung Ihrer Handydaten in einer Funktion Abfrage informiert werden,
die Staatsanwaltschaften halten sich nicht dran selbst dann wenn Bürgerinnen und Bürger der schriftlich verlangen du kannst ja sogar hinschreiben sagen hier ich möchte wissen habt ihr das gemacht mit mir.
Und dann sagen sie mögen sie dir nicht und argumentieren,
du willst es ja eigentlich gar nicht die Information interessiert dich ja gar nicht du hast ja nur ein schriftlichen Brief geschrieben um danach zu fragen das heißt ja noch lange nicht dass es dich interessiert,
und der Aufwand ist ja verunfallt ist mäßig hoch dass ihm die rauszusuchen deswegen lassen wir das lieber sein es gibt aber,
den Berliner Justizsenator Behrendt der von anderen Meister interviewt wurde und.
In Aussicht gestellt hatte dass es da ein Pilotprojekt geben wird was in den kommenden Wochen.
Staaten wird und das wäre dann also ähm wie so ein Online Portal wurde dann halt gucken kannst ich bin mal gespannt ob und wie sie das auf die Kette kriegen.
Aber es ist schon tatsächlich so ist meistens wirklich bei dieser Anzahl von Funkzellenabfrage dann als in Berlin lebende Person äußerst unwahrscheinlich da nicht dabei gewesen zu sein.
Ja ich frage mich ob du auch Fähigkeiten Mobiltelefone sich alternativ auch über WLAN einzubuchen eigentlich nur mit einer Frau mir auch schon berücksichtigt wurde.
Die halten sich ja parallel trotzdem in der Funkzelle auf.
Na ja wenn du das ausschaltest nicht.
Ja also bring die jetzt bitte nicht noch auf so scheiß Ideen weil das irgendwie ich meine Freiheit auch langsam ne also es ist schon irgendwie.
Nee ich meine ja nur wenn so einen WLAN-Hotspot und vital eine Demonstration ist und man dann wieder rüber erstmal.
Wie gesagt du bringst jetzt nur auf scheiß Ideen also ich finde das echt irgendwie das ist nicht irgendwie irgendwie so ein.
Was heißt auf die leichte Schulter zu nehmen ist das Kommunikationsinfrastruktur der wir vertrauen und du wirst einerseits irgendwie ausgelacht wenn wenn du 2018 noch,
von.
Und irgendwie zu sagen dann machen wir halt auch WLAN halt nur dazu dass sie sagen alles klar dann wollen wir jetzt hier demnächst die WLAN zu orten und so also.
Werbe ZW3 das Zentralregister sozusagen auslesen.
Genau oder dann eben sagen sie wenn das Telefon sich mit dem WLAN verbindet und darüber voice over LTE macht dann soll es bitte auf seine GPS Location mitschicken.
Weil sonst am Ende Schutzlücke so also geht ja nur noch so.
In den USA auch eine interessante Meldung gibt also die securus securis.
SecureCode Plattform die also im Prinzip.
Ninja Verfolgungsbehörde als Dienstleistung anbietet von jedem Telefon jederzeit irgendwo die Location zu finden,
die machen das anscheinend nicht über irgendwelche ss7 Angriffe die welche auch schon länger besprochen haben sondern sowie cory Doctorow,
wird es kalt doch dabei Ballenwagen scheint es dass sie Mobilfunknetze.
Eine Schwachstelle in den privacy also in den Privatsphäre Gesetzen benutzen dass sie nämlich quasi mit Vertragsabschluss deine Zustimmung.
Bekommen das sieht eine Location Daten verwerten und auch an Dritte verkaufen dürfen und dieses secureear kaufen die eben und wie wie das eben.
Überraschend immer wieder wirklich sehr zu schweren Überraschung aller dann rauskommt nutzen natürlich dann die Polizisten die darauf zu Gefahren er das für allen möglichen Scheiß.
Und im nutzen derzeit jetzt irgendwie als Hobby in äh.
Oder zu überwachen Ihre Ex-Freundin Freundin Freunde.
Genau das ist also.
Das alles schon nicht ausgedacht jetzt ne.
Nein das dauert schreibt er ja auch so ein Croquet im Korb Korb und das sind dann eben nicht die.
Üblichen Einzelfälle sondern mein wenn man solche Systeme baut und die eben ohne großartige Kontrollen in die,
in in die Hände dieser Menschen gibt dann heißt das eben dass das Risiko mit dabei ist nicht nur das Risiko sondern dass man mit dem Kauf nimmt das eben die schwarzen Schafe,
das auch in ganz einfach benutzen.
So zurück nach Deutschland.
Wie wir schon immer gesagt haben ich habe ja also dafür ja tatsächlich sage ich ja auch schon inzwischen seit Jahren.
Amela.
Ist ja nicht.
So Sack und Pack also Heckmeck wird ja immer so verkauft als wäre das so oh mein Gott ein Angriff findet statt.
Los Männer an die Tastaturen wir hatten zurück dann steht er da Obers und sagt hat das so funktioniert das nicht reicht jetzt auch seit vielen.
Jahren erkläre ich das ja auch dass es ebenso nicht funktioniert weil ich aus eigener Erfahrung weiß dass du Mont spontan mal was zu haken dann doch immer ein bisschen anstrengender ist als man meint.
Weshalb ist selbstverständlich wenn man sagt man möchte jetzt sich ernsthaft in.
Soll ich mal mit kriegerischen in kriegerischen Auseinandersetzung oder in bewaffneter Konflikt Auseinandersetzungen mit.
Mit anderen Staaten in diesem Bereich engagieren dann heißt das man bringt natürlich die Schadprogramme vorher an.
Das heißt mein Mann findet die Schwachstellen mann mann für die Infektion durch meine richtet nur noch keinen Schaden an damit man eben im,
im Bedarfsfall spontan mit angebrachten Trojanern,
oder mit angebrachten Backdoors eben eine Schaden auslösen kann und genau das sagt jetzt eben Maßen auch irgendwo auf seinem ARD Morgenmagazin seinen Worten.
Das Ziel muss sein dass wir Sabotageakte vorbereiten können indem Schadprogramme,
in kritische Infrastrukturen eingespeist werden um vielleicht im Zeitpunkt X wenn es zu einer politischen auseinandersetzen Setzung kommt sollte diese scharf zu schalten,
der benutzen paar andere Begriffe aber meint genau das gleiche er will im Prinzip jetzt schon die kritischen Infrastrukturen anderer Nationen Hacken und die Möglichkeit haben vielleicht diese auch anzugreifen.
Völlig absurd.
Als er möchte sozusagen das Ausland digital vermin.
Um dann jederzeit da auf den Knopf drücken zu können und hier haben wir euch doch gleich gesagt was geht ihr gegen uns vor dann haben wir euch ja das ist natürlich genau diese Aufrüstung die wäre ja immer,
beklagt und als Drohgebärde am Horizont gesehen haben.
Ja immerhin wenn du jetzt langsam aber das will ich sagen sie das auch.
Schauen ich habe mir das irgendwie so pass auf ne okay der Satz ist einfach zu krass ich habe jetzt noch mal schnell geschaut ja also.
Wollte gerade sagen das wäre einfach zu krass ich muss das Korrigieren er sagt nicht dass das sein Ziel ist.
Sondern dass dass das Ziel ausländische Akteure ist Didi Didi das was er sagt ist einfach zu deutlich gewesen also er warnt davor dass dies andere tun.
Na meint aber dieser Gefahr muss man mit eigenem präventiv Schlägen zuvorkommen.
Und deswegen möchte er in der Lage sein den Gegner so zu schädigen dass die Attacke keinen Erfolg hat also mit anderen Worten er will genau das gleiche machen ne klassisches aufrüsten.
Aber was er was er machen möchte er will quasi Angreifer in dieses argumentiert er jetzt hier infiltrieren um deren Angriffe im Zweifelsfall abbrechen zu können umso absurder ist das.
Was er behauptet.
Also um so absurde quasi zu sagen na ja okay bevor die Angriffe bei uns machen wollen müssen wir die infiltrieren mitten im Präventivschlag also das ist ein.
Diese Beispiele die die hier nennen sind so skurril und so weltfremd das ganz klar ist warum ich ihn eigentlich geht ist sie wollen die Möglichkeit haben.
Andere zu infiltrieren präventiv mit anderen Worten so ne also wenn du wenn du sagst präventiv das ist das gleiche wie mit drohender Gefahr.
Kann ja sein.
Dass wir mit den mit unseren Freunden den Briten mittelfristig gar nicht mehr so gut klarkommen deswegen haben wir präventiv jetzt schon mal deren Infrastrukturen gehackt falls die irgendwann auf die Idee kommen sollten uns anzugreifen.
Diese Argumentation sind immer in solchen corner cases Ja und als wenn,
muss ich auch immer wieder sagen wenn ein Angriff auf deine kritische Infrastruktur droht dann verhinderst du den nicht,
dadurch dass du die Angreifer oder die kritische Infrastruktur der Angreifer infiltriert hast so hin dass du den dadurch dass du den Angriff auf deine kritische Infrastruktur abwehrt.
Und nichts anderes vor allem die Annahme die ja ja auch noch mit schwingt ist ja dass das quasi folgenlos sei ja.
Aber da er ja selber auch zuschlagen können soll kann es erstens sein dass er das tut,
Steinzeit. Wo man das gar nicht wollte ja durch einen weiteren Fehler kann auch schon sein dass die Installation dieses Mechanismus selber,
Kollateralschäden mitsichbringt dass man das System destabilisiertes man da irgendwas auseinander reißt was man gar nicht auseinanderreißen wollte und wenn man das bei kritischen Infrastrukturen macht.
Gefährdet man damit natürlich die kritischen Infrastrukturen.
Auch schon ohne irgendeinen großen Schalter umgelegt zu haben es ist mein Mann kann ja nicht sagen da ja also hier so euer Wasserwerk und so weiter der Staudamm läuft ja alles noch ja,
nur wenn ihr böse seid springen wir den,
na ja gut kann aber schon sein dass allein diese Maßnahme allein schon der Versuch diese Maßnahme zu installieren dazu führt dass etwas ganz anderes schiefgeht und vielleicht entsprechende Folgen hat also Finger weg.
Von kritischen Infrastrukturen das ist das was das Wort kritisch meint.
Und genau also dann schützt eure kritischen Infrastrukturen ordentlich,
mach das sorgt dafür dass da keiner reinkommt mysteri und und nutzt irgendwie die Tatsache dass es Leute versuchen nicht dafür aus im Prinzip einfach nur zusammen dann wollen wir das auch,
ja das ist es ist einfach nur Quatsch und diese kritischen Infrastrukturen die sind eben wie ich auch immer wieder leider feststellen muss in,
immer wieder auch teilweise mal in zweifelhaften Zustand und es wundert mich nicht wenn er der ein oder andere drin ist die Reaktion darauf ist aber eben ganz macht diesen Scheiß dicht und sorgt dafür dass das in ordentlicher Qualität geliefert wird und in ordentlicher Qualität betrieben wird,
und Nuss ist nicht aus um einfach mal zu Befugnisse zu fordern letztendlich genau das gleiche zu bekommen.
Das ist unlauter.
Clown und lauter hatten wir doof und das geht gar nicht Mamas gut dann.
Ja ich wollte nur sagen habe ich schon immer gesagt dass sie das wollen obwohl nicht fertig berichtete.
Heute da hast recht behalten.
Ja gut jetzt alle apokalyptische Szenarien ist einfach.
Ich auch einfacher zu Tage kommen.
Nämlich zu den Terminen.
Vom 22 bis 23 September 2018 also noch etwas hin finden in Dresden wieder die Datenspuren statt das Motto der Datenspuren ist diesmal macht nichts.
Also eine sarkastische sarkastisch überholte Gegenposition zum tuwat unter dem wir den Kongress hatten.
Soll also die Lethargie der Massen persiflieren aber auch mit dem Unterton keine Macht ausüben anerkennen ausspielen und so weiter.
Rumspielen.
Datenspuren finden einen neuen Ort statt das finde ich überraschend oder nicht überraschend denn der C3 D2 der ausrichtende.
Chaos Computer Club Dresden ist ja gerade umgezogen in seine.
Neuen in seine neuen Räume im zentralwerk in Dresden größeres Gemeinschaftsgebäude und das heißt man kann also da.
Dann die neuen Ort die Örtlichkeiten des C32 anschauen und dieses Gemeinschaftsgebäude das wird bestimmt wieder eine ganz große Freude aktuell ist der CFP schon offen das heißt ihr könnt jetzt eure.
Vorschläge machen für Vorträge und sonstiges was ihr beisteuern möchte und der schöne Datenspuren ist wir sind natürlich wie immer kostenlos.
Freier Eintritt wie bei der GPM auch nur wir kriegen das nicht hin.
Nein das.
WWE wann ist ein eigenen Hacker space haben dann machen wir auch kostenlose Veranstaltung.
Genauso so ziemlich aus ja was haben wir noch anzukündigen wir haben das anzukündigen was wir hier schon seit Wochen und Tagen ankündigen nämlich 256.
Ich lese gerade alle alle Zusagen sind beisammen alle unsere Gäste sind da das heißt wir könnten jetzt bekannt geben.
Wir könnten die theoretisch Maler bekannt geben darf er vielleicht auch mal was weil wir noch sind auch gerade es bis pieksen noch vor 13 Uhr Tickets klickbar vieles nicht mehr aber immerhin ja Mama.
Ja wir fangen wir mal dein an.
Tja gute Frage vielleicht mit einer Dame.
Ich würde anfangen mit Martina Renner.
Ja die kommt.
Hat zugesagt Martina Renner ist dabei Bundestagsabgeordnete der Linkspartei war im nsa-untersuchungsausschuss ist jetzt in den Breitscheidplatz Untersuchungsausschuss die haben wir uns mal eingeladen dass wir sicherlich ein spannendes Gespräch.
Da wollen wir mal bisschen gucken wie es so,
ab geht gerade bei der Politik dann wollen wir auch den Aktivismus ein wenig beleuchten und haben uns Arne semsrott eingeladen den wollten wir schon ganz lange mal dabei haben,
der hinter solchen Projekten wie openschufa steht aber auch vielen anderen Aktivitäten und.
Frag den Staat primär.
Ja genau frag den Staat also auch für ein Tausendsassa des digitalen Widerstands und wurde mal Zeit den mal hier in die sendung zu holen und wir dachten uns da wäre dann doch das der richtige Anlass.
Dann haben wir uns noch eingeladen geraldin Sebastian eine die Musik ist jetzt nicht hier mach mal noch mal.
Was noch mal von vorne oder was.
Neue Nummer Musikkanal Oliver.
Bis jetzt auch ohne Musik geben.
In vielen Bereichen aktiv insbesondere was so Entwicklungspolitik internationale Zusammenarbeit Afrika und solche Sachen angeht im digitalen Bereich aktiv sie,
in der digitalen Gesellschaft aktiv in der Republica aktiv und also auch eine sehr umtriebige Aktivisten in vielen Bereichen die wir teilweise eher so auch nur am Rande,
betrachten oder war doch sehr viel Überschneidung sehen da freuen wir uns auch auf ein sehr spannendes Gespräch mit vielen neuen Themen die wir mit euch noch nicht behandelt haben.
Ja last but not least haben wir Jan Philipp Eyrich bei uns auf der Bühne noch,
Europapolitiker und einer der Masterminds hinter der datenschutzgrundverordnung die ja dann 1 Tag vorher dann endlich mal final eingeschlagen sein wird vielleicht noch nicht unbedingt die richtige Zeitpunkt zu einem Fazit der Auswirkungen dieser Grundverordnung um dieses Jahr für Aufregung,
gibt aber sicherlich mal einen Zeitpunkt mal zurückzublicken,
was das alles so mit sich gebracht hat und wieso auf seine zukünftige politische Ausrichtung denn wohl so sein wird wie seine Erfahrung auf europäischer Ebene bisher waren er wird ja demnächst dem Herrn Habig nachfolgen in Schleswig-Holstein,
und wir dachten uns dass es doch ein schönes Paket für Logbuch Netzpolitik 256.
Das so haben wir uns das gedacht alles Personen die wir noch nicht hatten das war ja das Versprechen was wir halten muss.
Genau war nicht ganz einfach.
Weil ich mir nicht sicher bin ob wir nicht nee wir hatten Stefan Wehrmeyer mal.
Der hat ja auch bei frag den Staat der dass er mal gestartet den hatten wir schon also ich denke das werden viele interessante Gespräche und jetzt inzwischen sind wir uns auch sicher dass das Vorprogramm unterhaltsam wird.
Ja für immer aber das haben wir noch nicht so viel zu.
Da sagen wir noch nichts zu.
Und sofern.
Und hier die Aufkleber Sticker sind gekommen sind schon sind leider geil die müssen wir kümmern Foto von mit in den in den Beitrag machen.
T-Shirts wenn auch gerade gedruckt für alle die klug genug waren.
Sich ein zu ordern.
Sich eins zu ordern für diejenigen die nicht klug genug waren und trotzdem kommen können dann auch noch dort vor Ort.
Geringe Mengen.
Reste Mindermengen.
Mindermengen noch abgreifen oder auch nicht genau wir werden noch tschüss veranstaltungsplakat für euch haben zum Mitnehmen und aufkleben und andere lustige Sachen also.
Es ist für alles gesorgt jetzt fehlt nur noch ihr und wir freuen uns schon darauf.
Bester Ausblick auf die 256 gibt's dann in der 255 die ist dann irgendwie nächste Woche.
Und insofern denke ich mal,
Da werden wir glaube das sollte ich euch noch mal ich glaube dann machen wir noch mal einen kleinen Aufruf dann ne 255 was ist Vorprogramm angeht da wird er darüber sagen wir dann mal groß und zum programm gehen.
Nuckel 5, Neuwied.
Baumberger freiwillige.
Ja, gut dann passt das aber erstmal.
Damit danke ich dann noch Peter Christoph und Markus sehr herzlich.
Und ich danke allen anderen die Metaebene und Logbuch Netzpolitik und überhaupt das ganze Podcast Universum weiterhin unterstützen die Treue halten und.
Auch diese ganzen anderen Dingen in sozialen Interaktionen im Netz tun die Podcast helfen die ich es hin runterbeten möchte.
Was ich was du meinst.
Wasser oder Diskussion vorhin ich muss mich da noch ein bisschen bewegen tschüss.
Ciao ciao.